Our next act here
is just a one of a kind wonderful man.
He's so gifted and he's so all about our lord and savior.
Let me have a volunteer
Let me have a voluntere for tonight, where're we at
ok, I like martial arts
I like all the martial arts
Here, why don't you hold that
It's not real, don't worry.
Why don't you hold on to [this], all right
and you, why don't you put it in my back
I know this is not a good place to be
[crowd laughs]
[gigles]
[crowd is amazed]
So he slaps it and transfers and grabs.
so how he does it
interesting
yea, so...
Wren, you put this gun to my back
and D put this gun to my face
ill go slow
You want me to try and kill you?
Don't blow em yet
*Music*
Aim like this right, to try and turn the gun inwards.
yea, as you spin this way.
and then he puts this to his right hand
and like, tugs the guy like that
and then like, turns him around
like that right?
To make it all come together
is a little belt adjustment right before he does it.
you gotta do the distraction
yes, exactly, it's cool I'm just ajusting my
BAM
no, wait, that's not how he did it
ok, so uh the biggest changes to the script
originally we had it written that the boxing glove would hit the girl in the face
I think it would actually be easier and more consistent with
the full length of the story if it actually breaks out a window.
When he pulls out the rocket, instead of the rocket firing at a building
We get the man-of-steel syndrome
This guy doesn't kill anyone but he is causing untold amounts of damage
It'll be easier if the rocket flies out and hits a statue of Darkwing Duck
You said you have a statue model?
no, we can get one
This is a lot for a day
I think we can do it, I think we can do it
So, Wren, you've got to put the gun to my back.
Stick em up
I a bad situation, If you both pull the trigger you shoot each other
You don't really gotta move from this position.
Boom
after he pushes then snaps the gun off
he put it into his right hand
like very quickly somehow
I think he goes
Adjusts my belt
whoops nah I mucked that up.
yep
Almost
Oh No
This time if I am too slow, shoot me
These are heavy scenes
and not in the sense they are long
but in the sense that you are conveying a tonne.
in each one
You have I think too much car driving
its trouble for you
cars are moving, you need shots in the car
shots outside the car
gismoduck chasing them down, gismoduck grabbing the car
your doing car stunts
so you focus on maybe doing one moment
and being done with it
that my big red flag, is all the car driving stuff
your not gonna be able to shoot the other two scenes and do that
all in the same day
I just want to get one solid shot
of gismo like chasing down a car
it would be cooler with the cars, don't get me wrong
but from a feasibility point of view
some of the other videos we have done recently
all those videos have done great
they were all shot in a day
it wasn't really about the spectacle of it
as much it was about character moments
what you are really looking for are these moment of gismoduck as a character
yeah and those are in there and those are the easiest parts of the thing
so lets focus on those and make the production easy
Put em up
oh okay, okay
alright guys
please dont shoot me ill give you my wallet give you my wallet
I was like im gonna shot you as soon as you touched my gun
and you almost ripped it out of my hands before I could fire it.
so it kinda works
it kinda works a little bit
lets try and straight it up after this
I am gonna try it
I wanna be a mugger
punching a woman in the face is funnier
you just slap stick
The boxing glove breaking the window is just
its not character on character interaction
its not messing up
It sounds awful to say it
I hate beating women
but it is really funny, no
i established what was going on with gizmo duck right off the back
i think, here is the thing
even if you know nothing about these characters
if you know nothing about gizmo duck
and he breaks a windows, its , okay
he just missed
vs he pops the wrong person in the face with his boxing glove
then it makes sense
yeah I mean I get that
that why I had it written in the first place
but, I dont know, I like
I think you should keep it character base
the darkwing duck statue
aye aye aye aye whoa whao
gimmy your wallet, gimmy your wallet
I am just going for my wallet
you can blow up the dark wing duck statue but the biggest thing here is
you want gizmo duck to be embarrassed right
hes your main character, so you want
you want him to constantly be doing things at the beginning that are
muck up some level
that make him feel bad
cause right now
what what we have talked about right now, you have a great setup
it is totally shootable
and you have a great middle character moment
so
lets just figure out this ending
looks like Wren has a V 6 to write
many things come to mind when you think of a David fincher film
Finchers true trade mark is deception
and it is accomplished primary through the use of CGI
and digital compositing
it is about how you use that technology to communicate that vision
and tell the best story you can